oh sorry Obama is terrorizing the city
of Austin Texas on Sunday night two
cyclists were injured after setting off
what appears to have been a tripwire
connected to a bomb it's the fourth
bombing in that city in just three weeks
Terry Turkey is a former FBI deputy
assistant director of counterterrorism
he joins us tonight Terry thanks for
coming on
so is there from what we know about
these explosions is there anything that
connects them a theme well I don't think
we know of a theme that connects them
right now the best information Tucker
we're going to have is the forensics
aspect of them that's what's going to
help us at least in these initial days
to try to put all of this together
because the people at the lab ATF lab
the police lab that the FBI's lab are
going to be able to look at every little
aspect of of crime debris of things
found at crime scenes and everything
from switches and bombs to the explosive
main charges to the way the containment
vessels were designed all of these
things are part of the Bombers signature
so they're going to be able to tell us
first of all if they've ever seen
something like this before even for
example you talked about trip wires so
one of the things that trip wires
conjures up is the idea of somebody
maybe from the military or maybe someone
who was part of some guerrilla movement
guerrilla warfare movement at some point
in time they can go back and make some
educated guesses of the person's skills
and talents from where they picked them
up from looking at the way the bomb was
assembled and and then we go from there
but you you just can't underestimate
particularly now that we've only had and
I say only it's it's very sad and tragic
but that's not a lot of bombings to to
be able to tell a lot yet although a lab
can tell a great deal from the forensics
huh so there was early speculation
reckless speculation by the press that
these were racially motivated which
obviously the last thing this country
needs now it looks like the victims were
black white Hispanic so there's no
obvious racial pattern here again thank
heaven but can you think are there other
motives that come immediately to mind
well I'm glad you asked that because
here's what I learned from you no bomb
and and from the Olympic bombing Tucker
even in leading the task forces there we
tried to stay away from motive now
motive isn't
important if you may have a name but
when you're trying to get on the trail
to identify subject you can absolutely
find yourself definitely in the swamp
and think back just a couple of examples
after the Oklahoma City bombing all of
the uproar and all the crying about the
Middle Eastern Arabs quote being
involved in that that turned out to
obviously be a domestic terrorism but
think about anthrax in the aftermath of
the 9/11 attacks and then the anthrax
attacks which were just literally weeks
later there was this tremendous push to
literally blame that on saddam hussein
in iraq and in fact I can tell you
straight out that the FBI at that point
in time was involved in confrontations
with the Department of Justice to slow
that faking the I remember even then
early on exactly even though I remember
Bill Kristol getting out there and
saying yeah we think that Saddam did
this is a pretext for a war in Iraq it
was of course all lying in propaganda as
usual quickly that these were not sent
is that correct these were placed
apparently outside homes that seems odd
to me it is odd and here's what it
suggests when you go into a residential
neighborhood and you walk up on
somebody's porch and you place a package
or you go out to another residential
neighborhood and you take the time
that's required to place and then set
and prepare a tripwire bomb to go off
you're really probably familiar or at
least at the very least feel very
comfortable in that kind of surrounding
give you a quick example two bombings in
1982 and 1985 at Quarry Hall in UC
Berkeley as part of the Unabomber series
of events well why was that so
comfortable for somebody to go into the
narrow hallways of quarry Hall twice
well as it turns out the alert Kaczynski
taught math at the building right around
the corner so those are the kind of
things that we can learn from the past
and hopefully those are the kind of
things we can apply to these kinds of
situations now because right now even
though it does appear very random and
very tough I guarantee you that over
time as they stay with the facts and and
they separate fact fiction in theory
right they'll start seeing patterns
develop that will be unique and
applicable of the person they're looking
for and eventually they'll be able to
give the public the right information
and
we know from the history of working
together at law enforcement the meeting
the public all of these kid things could
be brought together in salt well that's
what Apple if you're wrong of course
Terry thank you very much
good to see you tonight